[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur TV 78 nous sommes
le mardi 15 novembre 15 novembre voici
le programme à quand le plein emploi
pour les personnes handicapées c'est
l'une des thématiques de la 26e semaine
européenne pour l'emploi des personnes
en situation de handicap l'objectif
sensibiliser les employeurs et faciliter
l'accès à l'emploi nous en parlerons
avec nos invités de fasciveline et de
dams entreprise qui s'engagent pour
recruter autrement c'est la dernière
ligne droite pour les Bleus avant la
Coupe du monde de football au Qatar
toute l'équipe s'est rassemblée hier
lundi 14 novembre pour un stage de deux
jours intensifs et ce soir a lieu le
dernier entraînement à Clairefontaine
l'occasion de peaufiner les derniers
détails nous retrouverons sur place les
journalistes de la rédaction Michael
côté Grégory canalet le mardi c'est le
jour de votre page culture dans le 7 8
au programme de ce soir un spectacle
immersif au château de Maisons-Laffitte
sur la Belle et la Bête une exposition
sur Charles de Gaulle à Poissy et nous
parlerons également du festival le blues
sur scène à Mantes-la-Jolie et
d'ailleurs nous retrouvons Gabriel le
Gontier journaliste de la rédaction avec
Céline Charles pour le lancement de ce
festival à Mantes-la-Jolie Gabriel
comment ça se passe sur place
vous pouvez le voir derrière moi les
installations commencent à se mettre en
place les artistes étaient en train de
répéter encore il y a quelques minutes
le premier concert se déroulera à 20h ce
soir avec moi Chantal sipeletti et
Sébastien Picot nous en parlerons en
seconde partie de ce journal un super
Gabriel du coup nous vous retrouvons
dans quelques instants dans la seconde
partie de cette émission avec moi
également un plateau Laurence et mes
dangers bonsoir vous êtes chef de projet
pour face Yvelines je le disais à
l'instant c'est la 26e semaine
européenne pour l'emploi des personnes
en situation de handicap et vous
organiser ce jeudi 17 novembre la
quatrième rencontre de l'inclusion mais
tout d'abord est-ce que vous pouvez nous
présenter ce que c'est faciline alors
fascibling c'est la Fondation agir
contre l'exclusion on est un club
d'entreprise et nous animons pour le
département des Yvelines un dispositif
gouvernemental qui s'appelle les
entreprises s'engagent et donc on
reviendra pour parler de des rencontres
de l'inclusion tout à l'heure dans
quelques instants avec nous également en
plateau Laetitia Duvanel bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes directrice générale associée
chez dams et donc c'est une entreprise
des services autour de la téléphonie
mobile et vous êtes engagé pour
développer et favoriser l'inclusion à
travers le dispositif gouvernemental les
entreprises s'engagent club des Yvelines
un programme qui est déployé au niveau
territorial par face Yvelines que vous
avez décidé de signer pourquoi tout à
fait on a signé il y a deux ans parce
que ça fait partie de nos valeurs
fondamentales et on veut laisser la
chance à toutes les personnes de venir
travailler chez nous voilà pour donner
du sens aussi à notre entreprise et donc
on développera également un second dans
un instant avec moi également Régine
rallès journaliste de la rédaction de TV
78 vous allez nous parler des
informations d'aujourd'hui alors oui
effectivement aujourd'hui on va parler
de chômage mais également de la journée
mondiale
écrivains qui sont en prison et ce sera
juste après la météo je vous propose de
regarder quel temps il fera demain
[Musique]
demain matin dans les Yvelines le ciel
sera plus vieux attendez-vous à avoir de
rares averses au niveau des températures
il fera 9 à 10 degrés en moyenne dans
l'après-midi le soleil sera un peu plus
présent mais le ciel le restera tout de
même nuageux au niveau des températures
comptées 12 à 13 degrés en moyenne le
point maintenant sur les informations
d'aujourd'hui
[Musique]
le chiffre du jour quelle est-il
5 le chômage a baissé de 7,5% dans les
Yvelines de septembre 2021 à septembre
2022 le Pôle Emploi enregistre cependant
une légère hausse des demandeurs
d'emploi qui est de plus virgule 0,1 qui
est de plus 0,26% entre les mois de
juillet et de septembre 2022 et toujours
sur la thématique de l'emploi de
nouveaux modes de recrutement sont mis
en place dans les Yvelines oui
totalement et c'est plutôt original ce
matin à plaisir des recruteurs et de
demandeurs d'emploi ont joué ensemble au
rugby alors pour rentrer un peu plus en
détail c'est le Pôle emploi qui a lancé
du stade vers l'emploi donc qui est une
nouvelle manière de recruter la journée
démarre avec une pratique sportive donc
ça peut être du rugby ou de l'athlétisme
par exemple des équipes anonymes se
forment c'est-à-dire qu'on ne sait pas
si on joue contre des recruteurs ou des
demandeurs d'emploi et ensuite
l'après-midi l'anonymat est levée
commence donc on écoute tout de suite
les interviews récoltées par Nicolas
dandry alors la Ligue dans ce cadre là
mais en relation
les candidats et les entreprises
recrutés par Pôle emploi avec un club de
rugby de manière à les mettre dans
l'ambiance rugby et les amener à avoir
un job dating qui soit fructueux c'est
une c'est une belle initiative pour moi
c'est la première fois que je connais
qu'il y a d'autres façons de recruter
sans son entretien d'embauche direct on
retrouve vraiment des valeurs de
cohésion qui sont assez intéressantes
aussi dans ce sport et puis et puis elle
a envie de voilà de faire les choses
ensemble donc non non plutôt très
intéressant comme sport
une autre information Régine on va
parler solidarité maintenant exactement
donc les colis solidaires reviennent à
Guyancourt depuis hier le Secours
populaire les maisons de quartier et les
centres sociaux de la ville relancent
l'événement et ce jusqu'au 14 décembre
alors pour participer il suffit de
placer dans une boîte un vêtement chaud
on a également un produit d'hygiène neuf
une gourmandise un loisir donc un loisir
ça peut être un livre ou bien un jouet
et enfin il suffit de glisser un petit
mot gentil donc pour déposer vos colis
vous pouvez vous rendre dans les lieux
qui sont affichés à l'écran et à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux des
revendications ont lieu à l'école
Eric Satie vous pouvez nous en dire plus
effectivement nous des parents d'élèves
estiment que les conditions d'accueil de
leurs enfants dans cet établissement se
sont dégradés après les vacances de la
Toussaint l'éducation nationale a fermé
une classe alors même que une vingtaine
de réfugiés Ukrainiens sont scolarisés
depuis cet été un compte en moyenne
aujourd'hui 29 prélève par classe
pourtant le gouvernement s'était engagé
à réduire les effectifs au nombre de 24
donc les représentants des parents
d'élèves se sont réunis ce matin dans la
cour d'école ce matin donc mardi 15
novembre pour dénoncer la situation et
on termine les infos du jour avec la
Journée mondiale des écrivains en prison
effectivement donc cette journée c'est
l'occasion de d'attirer un peu
l'attention sur les journalistes et les
écrivains qui ont été emprisonnés à
cause de leurs écrits donc une table
ronde se tiendra d'ailleurs ce soir à la
Commanderie high en cours à 20h30 avec
des auteurs concernés et on en parlera
tout à l'heure avec notre journaliste
Julien Leroy merci beaucoup Régine
ralech et bien sûr comme d'habitude si
vous vous avez vu sur le terrain à côté
de chez vous une information que vous
souhaitez nous partager n'hésitez pas
avec le hashtag 78 news
on en parlait tout à l'heure c'est la
Semaine européenne pour l'emploi des
personnes en situation de handicap et
pour en parler nous sommes avec Laurence
et méninger chef de projet pour face
Yvelines et Laetitia Duvanel le
directrice générale associé chez dams
Laurence et messager face Yvelines
déploie au niveau territorial le
dispositif les entreprises s'engagent
club des Yvelines est-ce que vous pouvez
nous expliquer quel est l'objectif de
cette de ce dispositif alors les
entreprises s'engagent c'est un
dispositif qui vise à mobiliser les
entreprises en faveur de l'inclusion et
de l'insertion professionnelle des
publics les plus éloignés de l'emploi
donc le spectre est très très large ça
va être les jeunes les seniors les
personnes en situation de handicap et
donc cette semaine est particulièrement
intéressante ça va être également les
résidents des quartiers prioritaires de
la ville les réfugiés les personnes
classées sous-main de justice et en
résumé le point commun à toutes ces
personnes c'est que souvent elles n'ont
pas les codes de l'entreprise elles
n'ont pas de réseau et notre objectif
c'est de mobiliser les entreprises et de
les mettre en relation avec toutes ces
personnes et donc justement
vous les pour dams est-ce que vous
pouvez nous expliquer en quoi est-ce que
vous êtes engagé bien sûr donc nous on a
racheté la société il y a presque 2 ans
et on a eu un entretien avec Laurence à
cette même date là on s'est dit
maintenant on a un peu de pouvoir et on
a pris ce pouvoir de faire changer les
choses et donc on a coché pas mal
d'engagements
alors on a coché le fait d'accueillir
des stagiaires donc elle était les
stagiaires de 3e les stagiaires aussi
des BTS et des masters on a aussi choisi
de s'engager sur les personnes en
situation de handicap les personnes sous
injustice on a aussi choisi de donner du
temps au dispositif créé par Pôle emploi
sur des personnes de 45 ans et plus en
recherche d'emploi donc on a vraiment
mis ça en place mais très rapidement et
on a pu aussi participer au campus de
l'inclusion qui nous a fait aussi faire
un grand step aussi par rapport à nos
actions alors vous parlez du campus de
l'inclusion qu'est-ce que c'est le
campus de l'inclusion alors plus en plus
de l'inclusion c'est un programme qui
est destiné aux dirigeants pour les
sensibiliser les acculturés et mettre en
place un programme d'action très
inclusif de façon à ce qu'il puisse
comme ils ont le pouvoir vraiment
décider de changer les choses dans leur
dans leur société est-ce que vous avez
eu beaucoup d'entreprises qui se sont
engagées qui ont signé votre charte
alors aujourd'hui on est à 215
entreprises on a démarré en pleine
période covid donc l'inclusion à ce
moment là était pas très audible pour
les entreprises et néanmoins il y a 215
entreprises qui nous ont rejoints et qui
ont pris ces engagements en faveur de
l'inclusion c'est un objectif atteint ou
fixé encore plus de signatures alors
c'est un objectif en cours d'évolution
et donc tous les ans ont on mobilise un
maximum d'entreprises et on vise au
moins 100 entreprises par année et donc
ce jeudi 17 novembre vous organisez la
quatrième rencontre de l'inclusion
qu'est-ce que c'est alors cette
rencontre ça va être une grande
convention on va réunir justement les
215 entreprises qui nous ont rejoints et
à cette occasion on va faire des
partages de bonnes pratiques des
entreprises vont venir témoigner puisque
au démarrage les entreprises s'engagent
donc c'est un discours c'est un
engagement et ensuite certaines vont
nous illustrer comment sur le terrain et
au quotidien elles mettent en place tous
leurs engagements donc ce sera à
Versailles ça sera dans les locaux de la
Chambre de commerce et d'industrie de
Versailles Yvelines donc à Versailles
c'est important ce genre d'événements
justement pour les entreprises pour
qu'elles communiquent entre elles aussi
bien sûr c'est important de se retrouver
aussi entre nous de pouvoir aussi
témoigner de de ce que peut apporter
aussi de d'avoir ces équipes là et c'est
vrai que donner du sens aussi à son
entreprise c'est important on est en
entreprise à mission nous et notre
objectif c'est vraiment de faire
travailler les personnes qu'elles soient
et du coup depuis que vous avez mis en
place ce dispositif quels sont vos
retours
de qui de nos clients de nos seins de
l'entreprise des clients au sein de
l'entreprise c'est que tout le monde est
ouvert c'est vrai qu'on a intégré des
personnes
âgées plus jeunes des stagiaires qui ont
à peine enfin qui sont à peine majeurs
donc on a on a vraiment ouvert un peu un
peu tout pour accueillir toutes ces
personnes quelles qu'elles soient et de
vos clients du coup
ils sont très intéressés enfin ils sont
très contents de travailler aussi avec
des entreprises qui peuvent qui ont ces
valeurs fondamentales qui sont très
importantes ça fait partie aussi des
engagements et bien merci beaucoup
Laurence et Medinger Laetitia Duvanel
d'être devenu en parler avec nous en
plateau si vous souhaitez participer aux
rencontres de l'inclusion rendez-vous
sur le site internet qui s'affiche juste
en dessous on passe maintenant à notre
page culture
[Musique]
à l'occasion de la Journée
internationale des écrivains persécutés
la Commanderie d'Élancourt organise ce
soir une table ronde le but mettre en
avant le combat des journalistes et
d'auteurs pour la liberté d'expression
et Simon Suleimani journaliste kurde
réfugiés en France depuis un an et demi
suite au persécutions en Turquie sera
présent il a accepté de répondre aux
questions de Julien Leroy écouter
[Musique]
la Turquie c'est très connue des
journalistes impressionnant dans du
monde mais moi comment journaliste kurde
qui était toujours censuré harcele par
la police par le gouvernement c'était
vraiment difficile de de travailler
comment un journaliste là dans un région
trop chaud en colère toujours
mais c'était pas facile en fait
[Musique]
c'est pas facile pour tout le monde la
turc aussi mais pour les journalistes
c'est plus difficile parce que les
journalistes sont toujours emprisonnés
sans harceler
censuré mais si vous êtes journaliste
kurde c'est 100%. donc moi comment
journaliste après tentative coup d'État
en Turquie moi aussi j'étais en
prisonnier pendant 16 mois sans procès
dans un prison s'appelle la prison plus
sécurisée c'est pour les terrorisme nous
étions condamnés de faire propagande de
terrorisme dans notre pays
[Musique]
pour les cures de la France c'est un ami
très chaleur donc dans la région aussi
la France toujours soutient avec les
Kurdes et ici les peuple le citoyens
français ils toujours m aide les Kurdes
soutiennent parce que lecture des gens
connus en grand peuple sans état sans
pays là et ils ont toujours harcelé par
la gouvernement la dictatori en moyenne
ou rien
c'était première raison pour moi de
choisir France à venir ici
jusqu'au 20 novembre la ville de Poissy
présente une exposition intitulée
Charles de Gaulle l'homme derrière le
général les visiteurs sont ainsi amenés
à découvrir ou redécouvrir cette
personnalité emblématique l'objectif
transmettre au plus jeune l'histoire de
la France le reportage de Céline Charle
se souvenir du passé pour mieux
construire le présent c'est l'objectif
de la ville de Poissy à travers
l'exposition Charles de Gaulle l'homme
derrière le général à l'occasion du 52e
anniversaire de la mort de l'ancien
président l'exposition propose aux
visiteurs de découvrir ou redécouvrir
cette personnalité emblématique du XXème
siècle de sa naissance à sa disparition
il a quand même défendu aimer la France
défendue la France
transformer la France il a mis sa vie au
service de la nation il a été formé à
ces grandes idées de générosité et de
d'engagement je crois que c'est ça que
je souhaiterais transmettre peut-être
jeune il a fait un symbole un symbole
qui est très fort c'était la croix de
Lorraine là vous voyez le drapeau de la
résistance avec la fameuse croix de
Lorraine disons qui était un symbole
fort face au symbole nazi une exposition
rendue possible grâce aux
collectionneurs Piscia cake Guy Bouchard
il a mis à disposition de la ville une
centaine de ces pièces authentiques
elles proviennent toutes de sa
collection privée c'est la tenue 31 on
appelait ça 31 pourquoi parce que
elle a été faite du temps de Napoléon
III le 31 juillet 1837 qu'on se met sur
131 c'est rester comme ça c'était avec
la tenue 31 on a réuni deux collections
une collection sur 14 et une caleçon sur
39-45 on a quand même à peu près 9000
objets entre objets documents au lieu de
garder dans un grenier ou garder pour
soi ces objets et ben on préférait aller
montrer de vous montrer ça au public la
semaine l'exposition accueille des
classes de différentes écoles elle sera
ouverte au public le samedi 19 et le
dimanche 20 novembre
et j'ai été rejoint un plateau par
Mathilde Gadenne bonsoir bonsoir alors
vous êtes chargés de communication pour
la société de production Polaris et
Charles de Gaulle ça vous parle puisque
vous avez fait un spectacle sur Charles
de Gaulle c'était au Château de
Rambouillet en juin dernier oui tout à
fait secret défense en fait qui
retraçait la rencontre entre de Gaulle
et Eisenhower en juin 59 au Château de
Rambouillet donc voilà c'était la
première édition cette année et on est
heureux de pouvoir annoncer que le
spectacle reviendra face au succès qu'il
a rencontré en juin cette année d'accord
ok et donc là vous organisez un nouveau
spectacle sur la Belle et la Bête alors
est-ce que vous pouvez nous présenter un
petit peu ce spectacle tout à fait alors
il s'agit d'un nouveau spectacle
immersif au château de maison à
Maisons-Laffitte le spectacle donc le
sarticule autour du conte de la Belle et
la Bête il s'agit d'un parcours
spectacle d'une heure dans le château on
rencontre plus de 20 comédiens
professionnels 600 figurants et acteurs
qui jouent autour de nous des costumes
incroyables des décors époustouflants un
tourbillon de musique c'est vraiment
c'est une expérience immersive vraiment
on est plongé dans l'histoire en fait
justement c'est un spectacle immersif
c'est pas un spa un spectacle classique
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que les
spectateurs seront amenés à participer
au spectacle tout à fait en fait le
spectateur est vraiment amené emmener en
fait dans le château au nom d'un
parcours donc par les acteurs par les
figurants il y a un petit peu
d'interaction avec lui pendant le
spectacle il est vraiment plongé dans le
château plongé au cœur des décors en
fait pourquoi est-ce que vous avez
choisi le compte de la Belle et la Bête
c'est pas un autre compte
d'accord parce que la Belle et la Bête
c'est un peu le compte par excellence
finalement voilà avec cette princesse
cette bête ce prince voilà et puis aussi
parce que dans La Belle et la Bête le
château est un personnage à part entière
en fait dans ce conte et nous c'est vrai
que chez Polaris on a un peu cet
objectif de valorisation du patrimoine
et donc c'est très intéressant là de
pouvoir mettre en avant réellement le
château et voilà c'est vrai que dans ce
compte le château est ensorcelé hanté va
prendre vie et c'est très intéressant de
pouvoir retranscrire ça dans un
spectacle le château de maison à
Maisons-Laffitte retranscrit bien du
coup enfin il colle parfaitement au
château dans La Belle et la Bête il
colle plutôt bien fait avec des espaces
absolument extraordinaires comme cette
salle de Bâle gigantesque magnifique
avec tous ces lustres et puis ses
cuisines anciennes etc oui oui colle
plutôt très bien et donc vous avez un
peu revisité l'histoire ou ce sera
l'histoire comme dans le conte ou comme
dans Disney qu'on connaît alors j'aime
pas trop dévoiler mais il y a plusieurs
inspiration et c'est notre version
finalement de la Belle et la Bête avec
en effet des petits clins d’œil à Disney
des petits clins d'oeil à loto donc
voilà notre version la version Polaris
et donc tout à l'heure vous l'avez un
peu dit le nombre d'acteurs 20 et puis
un nombre de bénévoles impressionnant
600 comment vous faites pour organiser
tout ça est-ce que c'est pas trop
compliqué de faire tourner un peu le
spectacle et les répétitions avec autant
de monde tout à fait alors en fait c'est
la particularité de nos spectacles c'est
que chacun de nos spectacles
fonctionnent donc autour d'un monument
et avec une communauté de volontaires
locaux en fait qui connaissent le
monument le monument fait déjà partie de
leur quotidien finalement et donc là on
nous avons 600 volontaires de
Maisons-Laffitte alors pas tous de
Maisons-Laffitte ils viennent tous par
contre généralement du 78 parfois d'un
petit peu plus loin et donc il répète
pendant trois mois avant le spectacle la
raison d'une fois par semaine ou un
petit peu moins leur scène et puis voilà
il y a des répétitions générales où tout
le monde peut se rencontrer et jouer
ensemble et puis là en fait on a trois
équipes de volontaires qui vont ceux qui
vont se relayer pendant le spectacle
voilà non c'est une logique qui est
plutôt bien rodée et c'est vraiment très
très chouette de voir cette grande
aventure humaine en fait se créer dans
le château et donc là la première elle
aura lieu le 18 novembre ça va vous êtes
prêts vous peaufiner les détails tout à
fait vendredi du coup 18 novembre à
18h30 on lance le spectacle on est
presque prêt là les décors sont en train
de finir d'être monté les comédiens
répètent une dernière fois on fait les
derniers essayages de costumes mais ça a
bien se passer et justement comment
est-ce que vous trouvez tous ces décors
tous ces costumes parce que je me
souviens quand on était allé voir secret
défense à Rambouillet il y avait des
voitures d'époque comment comment est-ce
que vous trouvez toutes ces tous ces
costumes et ses décors et bien on a une
costumière et un chef décor absolument
remarquable qui travaille depuis des
mois sur sur cette production c'est
vraiment des des spectacles qui se
préparent très très en amont ça peut
être
différents différents lieux différents
endroits il y a une partie des décors
qui va être loué il y a une partie des
décors qui est chiné en brocante il y a
une partie des décors qui est
complètement fabriquée par une équipe
décor composé de certains de nos
volontaires donc voilà il y a vraiment
mille façons de créer ces décors assez
incroyables merci beaucoup Mathilde
Gadenne d'être venu en parler avec nous
en plateau je le rappelle vous êtes
chargés de communication pour la société
de production Polaris et si vous
souhaitez réserver une place le
spectacle aura lieu du 18 novembre au 18
décembre rendez-vous sur le site
internet qui s'affiche juste en dessous
on va parler musique maintenant on va
retrouver Gabriel Gontier qui est sur
place à Mantes-la-Jolie pour parler du
festival Blues sur scène cette année il
est placé sur le thème de la découverte
et de la diversité artistique et ça
commence ce soir nous retrouvons donc
notre journaliste sur place Gabriel vous
êtes avec Chantal sipeletti présidente
du festival et Sébastien Picot le
responsable de la programmation
exactement Mathilde ce soir se tient la
23e édition du festival Blues sur scène
alors depuis 19099 tous les ans le
festival se tient à Mantes-la-Jolie et
dans les communes alentours proposant
des artistes français européens mais
aussi internationaux avec moi vous
l'avez dit Chantal sipeletic alors vous
êtes la présidente du festival qu'est-ce
qui fait le succès de ce festival
Chantal alors je pense que ce qui fait
le succès de festival bien sûr c'est sa
programmation mais au-delà de ça ce
festival est un festival itinérant
c'est-à-dire que ce soir nous sommes à
la collégiale de Mantes-la-Jolie demain
nous serons peut-être à la nacelle à
Aubergenville à l'église de
fontenay-saint-père le jour suivant au
plus près du public et puis tous les
artistes qui vont participer au concert
tout public iront également dans les
écoles dans les collèges dans les lycées
dans les établissements médico-sociaux
au plus près
et alors justement on a dit depuis 23
ans
est-ce comment vous pouvez nous
présenter le festival quels ont été les
évolutions les temps forts de ce
festival alors ce festival est né donc
il y a un peu plus de 23 ans d'un groupe
d'amateurs de blues amantes qui ont
certainement
trouvé que finalement faire de la
musique à un moment de l'année où c'est
un peu gris un peu triste un peu froid
juste avant Noël voilà ce festival tous
les ans a pris un peu d'ampleur et
aujourd'hui
s'il était cantonné à Mantes-la-Jolie au
départ maintenant nous allons sur tout
le territoire de la GPSO alors vous nous
parliez de la programmation c'est vous
Sébastien qui vous occupez de cette
programmation comment on gère une
programmation pour un tel festival c'est
un véritable casse-tête Huawei parce que
comme je disais Chantal en fait la
particularité de boussu-sur-seine c'est
qu'on est itinérant sur tout le
territoire on a beaucoup de partenaires
en fait 90 structures qui sont associées
au festival notamment en fait des
structures culturelles avec lesquelles
on travaille donc tout l'enjeu pour nous
en fait c'est d'arriver à avoir un
calendrier optimisé en fait en fonction
des disponibilités de chacun et des
envies de chacun donc déjà à partir de
ça et puis après c'est faire le travail
d'une programmation on fait un peu le
point surtout les projets qui circulent
sur la né en cours sur des artistes
qu'on a découvert auparavant on
travaille tout un réseau de production
on repère un petit peu ce qui se passe
dans les salles de spectacles les
festivals et puis après beaucoup de
recherches aussi personnelles de
flâneries sur tout ce qui est YouTube
Spotify Deezer voilà on l'a vu la
programmation est très large il y a de
nombreux artistes les têtes d'affiches
est-ce que vous pouvez nous donner
quelques noms
écoutez on aura le plaisir d'avoir des
très belles dates sur le festival je
pense notamment à la soirée qu'on
organise au théâtre Simone Signoret à
Conflans-Sainte-Honorine où on aura un
double plateau avec deux artistes assez
incroyables Natalie anking et milesenko
qui nous reviennent tous les deux avec
des nouveaux projets qui sont qui sont
apparus cette année on aura aussi la
date au sax à HR avec tany cat Charles
en première partie et Robert kiné
des grands artistes qu'on a le plaisir
d'accueillir je pense aussi à la concert
qu'on organise à Andrésy le 25 novembre
avec une première partie d'un groupe qui
fait partie de la scène française du
blues qui est le French bloodsta et puis
surtout on aura le plaisir d'accueillir
un projet un peu inédit
ou Mathis Pasco musicien travaille avec
eux Coltman sur un projet assez
singulier donc voilà et puis d'autres
des belles dates qui seront présentes
tout au long de cette édition et qui
seront à découvrir du coup jusqu'au 26
novembre ce soir c'est près de 500
spectateurs qui sont attendus pour le
premier concert de ce festival merci
beaucoup Gabriel Gontier et du coup si
vous êtes intéressé rendez vous sur le
site internet qui s'affiche juste en
dessous blues sur scène.com j'ai été
rejoint en plateau par Nicolas dandry
journaliste de la rédaction bonsoir
bonsoir Mathilde et vous allez me parler
d'une initiative originale originale du
maire de la verrière
je vous propose de regarder tout de
suite ces images il y a le chapeau c'est
un bicorne orne d'une cocarde tricolore
vous avez aussi le pantalon avec un
galon de commandement puis la veste et
bien ce sont les éléments qui composent
la tenue traditionnelle d'un maire du
19e siècle Nicolas Dainville le maire de
La Verrière vient d'en faire
l'acquisition un costume acheté sur ces
deniers personnels je le précise auprès
d'un fabricant de tenue historique et on
écoute tout de suite le maire de La
Verrière
la branche d'olivier sur les broderies
qui symbolisent en fait l'autorité
civile
on a des petits boutons avec les lettres
RF comme République française une tenue
de mer qui en fait a été instituée par
un décret impérial sous Napoléon III le
1er mars 1852 et ce décret n'a jamais
été abrogé c'est important dans notre
période dans notre époque de pas avoir
peur de notre additions
et donc on a compris le volet historique
Nicolas dandry mais à quelle occasion le
maire de La Verrière porte-t-il le ce
costume
regarder ces images avec d'abord donc
une statue de la Marianne le maire qui
entre dans une salle avec la tenue et le
Code civil à la main on le voit entrée
alors si je vous donne ces éléments
est-ce que vous pouvez deviner Mathilde
je pense que c'est à l'occasion de
mariage mais voilà c'est ça une tenue
traditionnelle qui est portée qui était
portée déjà à l'époque au 19e siècle par
les maires lors de mariage mais aussi
lors de baptême laïque et ben c'est une
symbolique qui est très importante pour
Nicolas d'unville regarder
on avait envie d'offrir le meilleur pour
nos mariés c'est un jour qui inoubliable
c'est un moment solennelle c'est un
moment qui marquera jamais leur vie et
bien merci beaucoup Nicolas dandry pour
cette information
ça va peut-être donner l'envie aux
habitants de La Verrière d'aller se
marier et de voir du coup Nicolas
d'invite célébrer ce jour inoubliable
avec cette tenue de mer du 19e siècle
oui il a déjà eu l'occasion de porter
son costume plusieurs fois je crois
[Musique]
des mariages de derrière moi et de
derrière Waze avec cette tenue et donc
voilà c'est un petit clin d'oeil du coup
à ce côté historique et je sais que
Nicolas Dainville le maire derrière et
passionné d'histoire et du coup c'est
aussi un clin d'oeil rendu aux
traditions de la France voilà on
continue avec deux histoires puisque le
Salon du livre d'histoire revient à
Versailles ce week-end au programme
animation débat dédicace pour l'occasion
Patrice Karmous recevais Vianney malin
regardez je crois qu'on prend pas trop
de riz parce qu'on essaie de se de se
renouveler chaque année donc c'est c'est
très concentré sur tous les deux
après-midi du samedi 19 et dimanche 14h
18h30 c'est gratuit c'est ouvert à tout
le monde il y a pas besoin d'être gros
lecteur d'être passionné d'histoire
voilà on vient aussi découvrir un
morceau de Pulse de l'histoire de France
et du monde chacun sa façon alors le
fait d'associer évidemment l'histoire à
Versailles comme ça ça peut paraître
évident
justement c'est une idée qui est venue
tout de suite quand on doit proposer de
vous occuper oui c'était une longue
langue intuition en utilisant si on doit
faire un salon une fête de l'histoire
c'est bien Versailles bien sûr on pense
tout de suite au grand siècle le château
Louis XIV mais pas que voilà parce que
la Grande Boucherie de la grande guerre
de 14 c'est fini là le traité de
Versailles
l'amendement vallon la naissance de la
République s'est inversé je pourrais
vous raconter plein de choses qui font
que Versailles est au cœur de l'histoire
de France au cœur de l'histoire et et
justement l'histoire c'est aussi
un des un des fournisseurs si je peux
dire essentiel de la littérature que ça
soit que ça soit les romans ou que ça
soit les essais évidemment vous avez
tout à fait raison vous avez tout à fait
raison
je viens de prendre un petit déjeuner
avec Romain Sardou le fils de Michel
Sardou
et ils puisent vraiment sa source
là d'ailleurs il viendra avec un essai
pour la première fois une belle
réhabilitation du Moyen-Âge voilà oui
c'est ça oui c'est il est passionné par
le moyen-âge ce qui est alors évidemment
dans cette dans cette histoire de lire
vous disiez c'est très varié il y a en
effet des il y a en effet le Moyen-âge
et en effet de l'histoire contemporaine
vous avez un plateau absolument
formidable alors formidable ah oui un
petit peu quand même
soyons fiers après
c'est compliqué de faire une sélection
parce qu'on reçoit 181
et vous pourrez retrouver l'intégralité
de cette interview dans l'émission Yves
livre elle sera disponible prochainement
sur notre antenne et notre site internet
le mardi nous vous proposons de
découvrir une nouvelle thématique dans
votre émission le 7 8 l'astuce du chef
plusieurs chefs cuisiniers des Yvelines
ne vous livreront les secrets de leur
pour que vous puissiez ensuite les
reproduire chez vous et on commence avec
Virginie Legrand chef à domicile dans
les Yvelines elle nous montre comment
faire un palais de butternut avec du
foie gras une recette que j'ai eu
plaisir à filmer regardez bonjour je
m'appelle Virginie Legrand je suis chef
à domicile dans l'Île-de-France et
aujourd'hui je vous présente une recette
de saison originale et très colorée ce
sont des palais de butternut avec du
foie gras poêlé on y va
le butternut on est en pleine saison des
cucurbitacées là je j'ai fait des
tranches je les ai emporte-pièces en
fait et après je les ai blanchi
c'est-à-dire que je l'ai fait je les ai
passés 10 minutes à l'eau et là je vais
nettoyer au beurre
on va passer maintenant à la cuisson du
foie gras poêlé évidemment pas besoin de
remettre de l'huile du beurre parce que
le foie gras c'est gras
[Musique]
je vais couper
les morceaux dans ce cas là
je concasse
mes baies roses
j'ai détaillé mes suprêmes d'orange il
faut que vous enleviez toute la partie
blanche de la grume pour que vous ne
récoltiez finalement que l'essentiel
[Musique]
j'ai
du sel à la truffe
pour la déco c'est de la de la pistache
concassée les petites beros
framboise qui sont les dernières
[Musique]
la petite astuce c'est quand vous avez
fait cuire vos escalopes de foie gras
pensez bien à les éponger sur du papier
absorbant sinon votre assiette sera
remplie de gras et ce ne sera ni joli ni
bon bon appétit
est-ce que ça vous donne envie de goûter
Nicolas drer
forcément comme une proposez du foie
gras je peux dire que oui par contre
effectivement quand le foie gras est
cuit c'est vrai qu'il y a beaucoup de
gras et l'astuce est vraiment
intéressante et pertinente parce que
quand on vous mettait le foie gras vous
le transférez de la poêle à l'assiette
le grain dégouline est finalement c'est
une humidification vous avez apprécié ou
pas
j'ai eu plaisir de déguster et c'était
très bon vous avez pris autant de
plaisir à filmer qu'à manger ensuite
c'est ça vous allez reproduit l'assiette
après ou pas non non j'ai pas encore
testé de retester la recette non pas
encore mais en tout cas c'est une
recette parfaite pour les fêtes et du
coup si vous voulez vous aussi refaire
cette recette sachez que vous pouvez
retrouver le reportage bientôt sur notre
site Internet et sur nos réseaux sociaux
vous aurez ainsi toute la liste des
ingrédients j'en parlais en début
d'émission aujourd'hui c'est le dernier
entraînement des Bleus avant de partir à
Doha au Qatar et pour la Coupe du monde
de football et nous retrouvons Michael
el midoro sur place Michael vous êtes
avec les supporters quel est l'ambiance
sur place alors je suis précisément à
côté des
supporters sont juste derrière moi ils
font beaucoup de bruit pour cette séance
d'entraînement la dernière avant le
départ pour le Qatar en entendu les
irrésistibles français en tous les
champs à la gloire d'Olivier Giroud
Antoine Griezmann ou de Kylian Mbappe
ils sont environ 500 à peu près
aujourd'hui dans les Yvelines à la
claire fontaine pour soutenir cette
cette équipe de France cette équipe de
France qui du coup partira demain matin
aux alentours de 8h30 de Clairefontaine
pour la direction l'aéroport pour
prendre l'avion aux alentours de 10h30
depuis tout à l'heure les jours de
l'équipe de France se sont prêtés
traditionnelles questions à des
journalistes dans l'après-midi tous nos
confrères a été bien sûr présents pour
obtenir les derniers les dernières
réactions en vue de cette Coupe du Monde
qui commencera ce dimanche au Qatar on a
pu voir notamment Karim Benzema a donné
une interview sur nos confrères de
l'équipe ou bien d'autres rabiot pour un
Gazzetta dello
le journal italien donc le monde entier
est présent ici pour prendre la
température à quelques jours de ce
Mondial avec cette équipe de France les
joueurs français se sont ensuite
déplacés sur le terrain d'honneur qui
est juste derrière moi pour signer à
quelques autographes avec avec les
supporters on a pu notamment voir à
quelques mètres de nous à Antoine
Griezmann plaisanté avec les supporters
français ou encore Raphaël Varane ce
sera qui a dit qu'il était confiant en
vue de cette Coupe du Monde il y avait
bien sûr les stars qui a quand même
Benzema qui est Mbappé qui se sont aussi
arrêtés sont prêtés au jeu des
autographes et bien sûr des selfies et
là juste derrière moi il y a un petit
entraînement depuis quelques minutes on
peut le voir un petit match entre les en
remplaçant français et les surement les
titulaires on sait pas encore mais en
tout cas un petit match bien sympathique
on a pu voir à l'instant juste avant ce
duplex on a pu voir un but assez
somptueux de Kylian qui a croisé une
frappe dans un petit but et bien sûr
immédiatement a réagisse ils sont prêts
nos Bleus pour la Coupe du monde de
football je pense qu'ils sont prêts à
après à petit inquiétude quand même on a
vu quelques jours et courser cette
séance d'entraînement peut-être pour
être préservé en a pu voir Aurélien tu
vois Mesnil notamment rejoint les
vestiaires un peu plus tôt les gardiens
aussi à rejoindre le château qui est qui
a quelque part d'ici pour peut-être se
préserver ils ont pas poussé en tout cas
sur cette séance d'entraînement et bien
sûr le plus important c'est d'aller au
Qatar et c'est au Qatar qui qui faudra à
ce moment-là performer et bien sûr le
premier match de cette équipe de France
ce sera mardi prochain donc ils ont tout
le temps pour se préparer bon en tout
cas Michael je pense que ils vont pas
devoir s'adapter aux conditions sous
lesquelles vous êtes parce que il y aura
du soleil normalement au Qatar non
exactement j'ai pas regardé la
température mais je pense qu'on nous a
autour de 8 9 degrés beaucoup de il
pleut pas il pleut beaucoup et au Qatar
on sera aux alentours des 30 degrés dans
le sable quasiment donc oui ça sera pas
du tout les mêmes conditions dans 24
heures pour cette équipe de France
couvrez-vous bien avec Grégory canal
quand même oui oui on essaie on essaie
de bien se couvrir mais l'entraînement
va pas tarder à se terminer on ira
sûrement voir quelques supporters mais
on est bien couvert ne vous inquiétez
pas
merci beaucoup Michael midoro et vous
pourrez retrouver du coup prochainement
un reportage sur le dernier entraînement
de l'équipe de France à Clairefontaine
avant la Coupe du monde de football il
sera sur notre antenne et sur nos
réseaux sociaux c'est bientôt la fin de
cette émission mais juste avant de se
quitter je vous propose de regarder la
météo de demain
matin dans les Yvelines le ciel le sera
plus vieux attendez-vous à avoir de
rares averses au niveau des températures
il fera à 9 à 10 degrés en moyenne dans
l'après-midi le soleil sera un peu plus
présent mais le ciel restera tout de
même nuageux au niveau des températures
comptez 12 à 13 degrés en moyenne et
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi jusqu'au bout avec nous je
vous souhaite une belle soirée sur TV 78
prenez soin de vous
[Musique]